[Música]
Este martes tendrá lugar en Washington
la capital estadounidense el discurso de
Joe biden sobre el estado de la unión
será el segundo de su mandato y se
espera que hable sobre los logros de su
gobierno también que tienda la mano a
los republicanos para negociar el techo
de la deuda ampliamos desde Washington
en Chile son Ya al menos 26 los
fallecidos por los incendios forestales
que han consumido más de 300.000
hectáreas y cientos de viviendas el
mundo se ha solidarizado con chile y la
ayuda internacional sigue llegando este
lunes arribó a la ciudad de Concepción
el tentanque el mayor avión anti
incendios del mundo que fue enviado por
Estados Unidos
un tribunal argentino dictó cadena
perpetua para cinco de los ocho
jugadores de un equipo de rugby que en
2020 mataron a golpes al joven Fernando
báez Sosa los otros tres culpables
fueron condenados a 15 años por
considerarlos partícipes secundarios
Bienvenidos a Nueva informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos iniciamos en Estados Unidos
en Washington Este martes tendrá lugar
el segundo discurso de Joe biden sobre
el estado de la unión se espera que el
presidente enfoque su alocución en
destacar los logros de su gobierno sin
embargo temas como el de ampliar el
techo de la deuda también estarán sobre
la mesa biden aprovecharía su
intervención para pedir una vez más a
los republicanos negociar este punto
para evitar que el país entre en The
Falls según una encuesta publicada este
lunes la mayoría de los estadounidenses
ven con preocupación el déficit
presupuestario anteriormente nuestro
corresponsal en Washington Cristóbal
Vázquez Nos daba más detalles
este discurso de la unión se va a
Resaltar lo que ha hecho en los primeros
dos años de gobierno y va a proponer los
las políticas que espera hacer y espera
lograr los próximos dos años se
centrarán el tema de la inflación que
fue una de las promesas claves que hizo
en el último discurso de inflación de
precisamente bajarle los precios a los
estadounidenses ahí
se pegará de alguna forma de los abuelos
datos que ha arrojado la reserva federal
y los pronósticos de los economistas de
que el próximo año empezando el próximo
año pues la inflación estará pues es
justo cerca al 3% en Estados Unidos una
cifra muy inferior a lo que vivió
Estados Unidos en el 2022 en cuanto a
inflación también hablará de cómo ha
logrado bajar los precios de los
medicamentos y marginalmente también
como ha logrado bajar los precios de la
energía en Estados Unidos logros que
seguramente resaltará y hará
énfasis en el hecho de que las empresas
grandes empresas en Estados Unidos van a
tener que empezar pronto a pagar su
justa tajada en cuanto a impuestos como
lo ha repetido veces el presidente sin
embargo recordemos que en este intento
para que las multinacionales y las
grandes empresas acá en Estados Unidos
pagarán más impuestos pues no pudo
lograrlo porque no fue aprobado ese
intento de subir los impuestos a las
grandes empresas precisamente para
financiar este déficit y esta deuda que
está en negociación
el portavoz del Consejo de Seguridad de
la Casa Blanca John Kirby aseguró que
había pruebas de que durante el gobierno
del expresidente Donald Trump al menos
tres globos chinos similares
sobrevolaron el espacio aéreo de Estados
Unidos entre tanto el gobierno de China
confirmó que el globo que fue visto en
cielos de algunos países de América
Latina es de su propiedad Beijing Indicó
que se trata de un globo de naturaleza
civil y es usado para pruebas de vuelo
pero por accidentes se desvió de su ruta
descubrimos estos vuelos después de que
asumimos el cargo y no voy a entrar en
detalles sobre cómo hicimos los análisis
forenses creo que pueden entender que
vamos a tener cuidado pero nos dimos
cuenta de que en al menos tres ocasiones
los globos de vigilancia de la República
popular china transitaron por el espacio
aéreo de los Estados Unidos
el mundo se solidariza con chile país
que sigue haciendo frente a la
emergencia desatada por los incendios
que hasta el momento han dejado 26
personas fallecidas y 300.000 hectáreas
arrasadas así como unas 800 viviendas
afectadas el gobierno central liderado
por el presidente Gabriel boric decretó
el estado de catástrofe en las regiones
afectadas por las llamas en la jornada
de hoy arribó al aeropuerto de la Ciudad
de Concepción procedente de Estados
Unidos El tentener el avión para la
lucha contra incendios de mayor tamaño
en el mundo
chile lucha por controlar las llamas Con
vientos moderados y temperaturas por
encima de los 40 grados centígrados el
sur del país se ha visto afectado por
más de 250 incendios activos de los
cuales 80 están fuera de control según
informó el servicio nacional de
prevención y atención de desastres y
ahora ya me dijo que había que esperarla
hasta el final para poder salvar la
casita que ustedes ven acá y el taller y
todas las cosas los animales Así que
esperamos Hasta el final pero el hecho
de esperar hasta el final nos tocó la
pasó la cuenta y
lo encerró el juego el fuego afecta
especialmente a tres regiones del país
la araucanía bío bío y ñuble que se
encuentran bajo estado de catástrofe lo
que permite movilizar recursos y la
mayor participación de las fuerzas
armadas esta zona del país se
caracteriza por tener poca población una
gran extensión de bosques y una gran
riqueza agrícola según las autoridades
al menos 270.000 hectáreas han
consumidas por las llamas y las causas
aún son desconocidas Pero hay al menos
10 detenidos por su posible vinculación
a los incendios cabe la menor duda que
estos incendios son intencionales yo
tengo 53 años y de toda mi vida he
encontrado botellas en el campo vidrio
que muchas veces han dicho que no que
son iniciados por un espejo que Porque
trabajas con una motosierra eso es
mentira acá esto hay una intencionalidad
claramente y obviamente ahí no hay nada
que hacer nosotros como vecinos
solamente Esperamos que llegue el fuego
nomás el presidente francés Emmanuel
macron también ofreció ayuda a Chile
para combatir el fuego mientras que
México Colombia Estados Unidos Ecuador
Brasil y Perú entre otros países de la
región también desplegaron asistencia
al menos 15 personas fallecieron en la
región peruana de Arequipa en el sur del
país según el Instituto Nacional de
defensa civil entre ellos tres menores
de edad todo a causa de un deslave
provocado por las Fuertes lluvias en un
Distrito minero de esta región la
policía se encuentra en labores de
búsqueda de los desaparecidos defensa
civil registró también al menos 320
viviendas afectadas
eso está hecho un desastre completo y
tenemos ahorita cuerpos regados están
muertos son más de mil familias
damnificadas no donde se puede decir que
de un 90%
ya no tiene validez sus viviendas no ha
sido completamente destruidas y cerramos
en Argentina donde un tribunal de la
ciudad de dolores sentenció a cadena
perpetua a cinco de los ocho jóvenes
indicados de haber matado a golpes en
una riña a Fernando báez Sosa en hechos
ocurridos en 2020 los otros tres
Implicados En el caso fueron
sentenciados a 15 años de prisión
algunos de los acusados indicaron que
apelarán la sentencia mientras que la
familia de la víctima pide la pena
máxima para todos los implicados
fue una decisión unánime los jueces en
el caso de Fernando báez Sosa condenaron
a cadena perpetua a cinco de los ocho
jugadores de rugby que mataron a golpes
al estudiante de 18 años fueron
considerados autores de homicidio
agravado por alevosía los otros tres
recibieron una sentencia de 15 años
pero la familia considera que el
dictamen no da justicia
Porque eran equipos son equipos son
equipos y asesinaron a Fernando en
equipo
ya que no estábamos conforme eso lo que
decía teníamos justicia la Argentina en
un país tan rica pero justicia es muy
vacía y este tribunal desde mi punto de
tuvo clemencia con tres acusados de una
manera irracional Ese es el ese va a ser
el motivo de nuestra de nuestra
apelación por su parte los ocho acusados
pueden apelar la sentencia Fernando báez
Sosa murió luego de una riña en una
discoteca entre su grupo de amigos y el
de los jóvenes que posteriormente lo
atacaron tras ser expulsados de la
discoteca los jugadores de rugby lo
agredieron por la espalda una vez fuera
del recinto lo golpearon hasta que cayó
inconsciente y una vez en el suelo le
siguieron propinando Golpes en la cabeza
el tribunal Consideró que el grupo había
planeado el ataque el caso suscitó una
ola de repudio en Argentina y Paraguay
de donde es oriunda la familia de báez
Sosa el juicio ha sido ampliamente
mediatizado tanto en el país como a
nivel internacional
así terminamos este repaso informativo
sigan conectados a France 24 y Recuerden
que pueden ampliar toda esta y mucha más
información en nuestro sitio web France
24.com
[Música]